[Music]
your desecration of reality
i mean
british museum filled with robots this
show's great
six chairs
we should tell him the truth i can't
believe they put that in the trailer
what it still blows my mind yo get out
of here man like it's just it's
i can't even believe it it's happening
it's happening
it is happening and uh what a new
chapter of mcu multiversal history we
are now entering
i can't believe it
welcome back to new rockstars doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
just through the multi-virtual doors
wide open and that door is in the shape
of an x that opens from the middle
because now we have patrick stewart
charles xavier from the fox x-men films
leader of the illuminati but what is the
illuminati did we all just become q and
on followers and what the box
x-men
this is inside marvel new rockstars
weekly marvel reaction show i'm eric
boss i'm here with mt
dude that trailer blew my mind just
straight on open i can't i need to know
what those little like ultron little
bots are doing there and like the
illuminati scenario like why did we see
everybody sitting in the chairs this
trailer was surpassed my expectations
blew my mind
yeah where are the other uh three the
other three are like still in the
bathroom they're like right
sorry everybody sorry sorry just
blow out of illuminati toilet paper
and what's his name oh he's one of the
doctor strangers okay
[Laughter]
i mean mt you remember just a few weeks
ago here on inside marvel we looked
ahead to multiverse madness and wondered
if professor x might show up in this
movie hell my big prediction for 2022
and our what we got wrong 2021 episode
was was really just that the fox x-men
would show up in multiverse of madness
patrick stewart included that felt like
a pretty big reach and then thank god
less than two months in i've avoided
another mephisto gate because it is
happening it is already happening we
know from the trailer happy valentines
but um in order to figure out professor
x's role in this movie we really got to
talk about why the illuminati is so
important in the emcee why it had to be
the illuminati if it is even the
illuminati because that oh bro i feel it
about bones it feels like illuminati to
me i hope so
yeah it's illuminati now um before we
get to this there are some brand new
shirts available at epicheroshop.com
inspired by our lord and savior mephisto
the unofficial marvel mascot here in new
rockstars they're both really really
cool designs uh one is a uh like a word
search and there's some other easter
eggs hidden in there you know i love a
shirt with easter eggs just get anything
to get people staring at my chest for
longer than a second before they throw
up immediately
so
that shirt's one there's this other
shirt that's like in the style of a
swedish death metal album cover that i
think i love even more
uh both are amazing uh and you can find
those in all kinds of unique marvel
inspired designs over at
epicaroshop.com and
newrockstarsmerch.com whatever is easier
for your little thingies to type uh now
mt what's our question kicking off this
week here at new rockstars bro i gotta
ask you bro what the [ __ ] is marvel's
illuminati and why is patrick stewart
charles xavier part of that team because
it sounds like the illuminati of real
life it's like the sketchy oh we're
controlling the government but is that
the same thing eric yes everything is i
have to
i have to say when you said what the fox
it's it's not like in our script outline
so i'm like whoa if he's going hard
to hear it
as something else for a second i forgot
that we were doing that
now let's let's explain what marvel's
illuminati is not to be confused with
the the real-life uh conspiracy theory
illuminati of uh the shadowy cabal that
yeah i don't actually believe in it
yeah it makes you wonder that they might
actually change the name of this lineup
in the mcu just to a wrong conclusion
the way that like in archer they changed
the name of the organization from isis
because oh my god yeah there was a lot
of isis things in the past that were
just like
um well uh so in the comics marvel's
illuminati was created by brian michael
bendis in 2006 it was formed after the
cree squirrel war and this group came
together to prevent earth from coming
under attack from future advanced alien
races the the different groups of marvel
heroes all thought like you know we
should kind of like have each other's
backs to prevent all of us from being
destroyed so really the brightest minds
from each of these divisions of humanity
joined forces in what was a secret
society kind of like a u.n world
security council but without any kind of
public awareness of what they were doing
and this lineup included tony stark who
uh this is really his idea you could say
uh he was you know of course the leader
of the avengers and he represented the
the common man with no natural
superpowers other than you know a
brilliant ability to engineer pretty
much anything um
but he's the one person on this group
who's like that uh then you have charles
xavier of course the leader of the x-men
uh and there on behalf of mutant kind
and then reed richards leader the
fantastic four considered at this point
to be the bright brightest scientific
mind on earth uh doctor strange sorcerer
supreme and the expert in all things
mystic uh and then you have black bolt
someone we have not met in the mcu uh
he's the king of the inhumans uh well
you could argue if the inhuman series on
abc was mcu cannon i don't think anyone
really argues that uh but uh yes the
inhumans the the group of the um
the cree genetic experiment on the moon
who look out for us black bolts actually
a pretty cool character yeah i love
black bald my dude he says the word can
level a mountain i actually have a huge
fan of the inhumans in the comics but
like the way that they've been handled
obviously in live action not the best
but like black vault super cool yeah
very cool guy uh and he was included on
the team really to try to connect
mankind to their ancestry because you
know inhumans obviously super old uh
then you have namor king of atlantis who
represents the whole anterior mindset
because he's a bad boy now namor uh in
the mcu has been speculated to be cast
as tanakh huerta perhaps for uh black
panther wakanda forever uh we'll see
that hasn't been confirmed yet it's just
been kind of speculated rumored really
one of my favorite details about tanaco
who's
i believe a pretty good actor uh he uh
is in the movie spectre in that elevator
in the opening long take following uh
james bond during the dia de los muertos
celebration there's a part where he just
goes in an elevator and there's another
guy making out with a woman in the
elevator that is uh our future neymar in
the mcu oh we'll find out okay so tony
stark yeah he initially brought in black
panther but black panther backs out he
doesn't trust this association will be
best for wakanda um now in the
multiverse of madness trailer doctor
strange comes before a tribunal of six
chairs one of which is definitely
occupied by patrick stewart charles
xavier which is just insane
so nice that's why we're jumping to the
conclusion that this is illuminati six
chairs one of them being professor x it
being connected to perhaps iron man and
uh and doctor strange um they might just
give it a different name but it's going
to be essentially what the illuminati is
however however comic fans will know
that like in the marvel comics the
illuminati isn't really a multiversal
governing body or tribunal that's new to
the mcu but i would say in order to get
perfect professor x on this the
professor x that we would immediately
recognize and get excited about it kind
of needs to be a multiversal body not to
say that everything they do will be like
a multiverse matter uh but i think this
is like the opportunity to introduce an
important function for the illuminati
that we have not yet seen in the mcu and
get them very excited about them i don't
think there's any problem making them a
multiversal governing body well they
sort of are in the comics in a way i
mean like they're they're not to this
extent because they seem like a more
like a council of rick's
type of like body here in the mcu but in
the comics like they though they were
you know stationed on earth they did
sort of try to stop the multiversal
incursions from happening into our
reality so in that way i think they're
just they're doing that but like in an
extra way in the mcu which i'm really
excited yes
yeah i guess what i'm saying is like
they definitely are aware of the
multiverse and threats that come from
the multiverse in the comics but they're
really just on one side of that
battlefront uh whereas like now they're
like above it all i think that's
fascinating to show them this way
because it gives us an opportunity to uh
bring in these characters some of whom
might stay in the mcu permanently going
forward or some who might come back in
other forms and some might just show up
in this movie as we saw in rick and
morty council of rex as you mentioned
like
they are seem like this huge
organization that like rick pretty
quickly deals with it
and rick and morty is 100 in this
movie's dna of course the latest draft
was written by mike waldron showrunner
on loki so all the parallels you're
seeing between this movie as it's
presented in this trailer in loki that's
not by accident i think he's basically
taking the loki formula of a multiversal
bad boy uh who gets and caught gets
arrested and brought in front of this
tribunal of oddballs and then he kind of
ends up either burning the place down or
tasked with protecting the place um from
some either even worse threat of
something that he was involved with so
there are really like three questions
that i have about this version this
particular lineup of the illuminati
question one who else is on it who is
that complete roster of it uh two how
did this organization form and three
what role do we think it will play in
the future of the mcu and i want to
start empty with speculation on who else
could be on this lineup let's run
through all the possible candidates the
people that we've seen in this trailer
people speculated to be in this movie
awesome people who we think should be on
it uh of course starting with charles
xavier uh can we just talk about patrick
stewart being in this movie bro the man
is not sweating for work and let the
student ask picard this dude is on a
roll like this dude is just working man
and i'm so glad to see him just
see that connection finally it's like
hello it's finally the x-men i hope he
just says that looks at the camera it's
time for the fox x-men everyone
and i have to say like i i i 100 agree
it's insane and he like
it hits me more emotionally almost than
seeing andrew garfield and toby maguire
that might sound sacrilege to some of
you guys i grew up with all of these
characters 100
but like and if they can get tobey
maguire to come out of his weird exile
to show up in these movies yeah they can
get patrick stewart you know patrick
stewart shows up everywhere he uh back
when um
back when live comedy was a thing
there's an amazing improv show called
improvised shakespeare that is based out
of chicago but does uh shows everywhere
and he randomly dropped in with
improvised shakespeare they they
improvised iambic tamiter and they're so
amazing and he dropped in and just did a
show with them of course he's a trained
shakespearean actor he's done plenty of
shows in his lifetime but so this guy is
just happy to show up he's just a super
music dude
but like hearing his voice in this
trailer like to me the the kevin feige
era of marvel movies started with
patrick stewart agreed to be
uh professor x like someone who grew up
with the 90s x-men series i thought like
as a you know as a kid i was like oh
that's perfect casting and he's never
proven me wrong and every time he shows
back up he was really i mean along with
uh hugh jackman he was the lifeblood
even when like hugh jackman was a part
of the movie when when just like patrick
stewart could could walk up and
everything felt okay you know it felt
like we were in good hands like
he's basically like the first superhero
shepherd because like he he's the head
of the head of the mutant academy so
like he's like hey come on superheroes
so like seeing him sort of like shepherd
doctor strange in a way it's like oh we
need to tell him the truth like sort of
like just shepherding him in on the the
multiversal scene i think it's really
special to see yeah and and you know
unlike toby and andrew i never went
through any like petty faces in my life
where i was like like i was a little
disappointed with what patrick stewart
brought to the table you know i never
was like oh okay
i never like pretend to be cool with
some lame friends by like dissing him so
like it's only just been pure wholesome
joy and delight at seeing
this guy involved with anything um okay
so we have charles xavier i think the
one confirmed lineup of this uh a member
of this uh and obviously he would
represent mutant kind so let's run
through the other divisions of the
marvel world uh the mystics the mystics
i have to imagine some sorcerer supreme
is on this panel and i think the
likeliest option is mordo based on the
trailer i think the mortar we see in
this trailer is immortal from another
dimension in which he is sorcerer's
supreme yeah i big time agree i think
that you know this mordo is really
concerned about stopping you know doctor
strange's in particular
from messing up the the multiverse and
you know in the passover supreme the
ancient one
definitely if if this council was around
she was on it there's no doubt in my
mind that she was aware and so um you
know i think that if that seat was a bit
vacant then that sort of supreme mortal
from another universe could have taken
her spot and um you know could have been
helping them out and is who
sort of shepherds or brings this uh
doctor strange in
i'm assuming so yeah more that mordo
seems like a really big candidate i
think so and i think he may be the
hooded guy who's sitting
off to the right um
but um
another person we see in this trailer is
someone who is like this mysterious
figure fighting wanda maximoff and
there's a lot of speculation on who this
is if it could be like the superior iron
man uh tom cruise we'll get to him later
i think in this case this person we're
seeing is actually some variant of
captain marvel or more likely photon
spectrum monica rambo maybe maria rambo
i just think looking closely this is
very clearly a woman of color she has a
womanly figure
she's fighting wanda in this moment i
think having wanda reunite with monica
rambo after they were both involved in
the battle of west view and one division
i think that's a very exciting matchup
um and and i think
what they might be doing here is uh
acknowledging the black bolt connection
to this lineup because the inhumans are
cree experiments and captain marvel
and her whole corner of the marvel world
all is kind of a mix of humanity with
cree technology of course derived from
the space stone but it is uh kind of the
cree project tahiti that that led to the
version of carol danvers that we saw in
the mcu and we don't really know fully
what monica rambo's history is with
carol danvers but we know she has some
history and i think her powers being
similar to captain marvel isn't an
accident isn't a mistake so i i i'm
wondering if like
a a super powered photon monica rambo in
an alternate timeline uh leading the
avengers as monica rambo does at one
point lead the avengers and comics uh i
think that's the version they're going
with and i think she's representing the
the extraterrestrial experiment on human
uh on humanity uh that black bolt
actually was oh yeah definitely i think
that um i think that's a really good
assessment for sure and about there's
also like uh other fan theories going
around like you mentioned this earlier
with maria rambo and how this could be
like a what if version of like what if
it was maria instead of carol and she
got the powers which would be really
cool because i was really sad to see her
be you know killed off at the beginning
of one division which was a bummer
because i loved her in captain marvel
and so it would be dope to see her come
back and for potentially her and monica
from our universe is just to have a
little goodbye that they never really
had got but when she passed away with
this variant mother so i would love to
see a maria but no a photon monica rambo
like you said because we had we saw that
sort of like a teaser face-off in one
division with uh with wanda like sort of
throwing her around um so i it would be
good to see them like actually face off
like monica versus wanda in in
multiverse badass i really love that
theory that uh it could be this what if
scenario of maria rambo uh callsign
photon who ended up getting the the
captain marvel powers you know i i think
that would be awesome to see and
especially if like we consider this
lineup um
some people who come back uh in the
multiverse uh or some people it's kind
of the door is kind of left open some
people we might just see once and we
just kind of explore it here uh that
kind of like
that
episodic feel to it is one thing that
rick and morty has some characters you
might see just as one episode any
character you could see come back
we don't feel like married to anything
um
that kind of sense of opportunity is is
one thing that i really love seeing
coming in the mcu
all right let's talk about reed richards
uh there is one like skinny stringy
figure sitting in one of those chairs
and i think now if you're bringing in if
you're bringing in patrick stewart
you're bringing in the mutants
you got to bring in fantastic four even
if it's not the reed richards you're
gonna stick with going forward some
alternate reality version of reed
richards uh looking at that silhouette i
don't think it's john krasinski uh it'd
be hilarious if they got joan griffith
from the uh 2005-2007 one i know in in
fans minds that that's not like the
definitive anything i would but like
you're just bringing him back once bro
like he needs to come to the fmcu like
as a mainstay as the maker bro because
the maker is one of like the
coolest or in my opinion like the
coolest mcu or coolest marvel villains
rather um because if you guys don't know
the baker is like an evil version of
reed richards from the ultimate universe
if griffin came back as a mr fantastic
and just like was like oh i'm good and
then he was like i'm secretly evil and
like i'm turning this council evil now i
would love that it would be the best
turn and like it would really help
incorporate that original fantastic four
team to a potential secret wars
narrative down the road um so i would
really dig that now if they aren't ready
to introduce reed richards i i had a
theory that i went into in the breakdown
that um there could be
a version of the the richards family
tree that descendants of having perhaps
suggesting that kang or nathaniel
richards or he remains some kang variant
either is currently or was
a member of the illuminati i just think
it's interesting that kang's citadel
that he he remains citadel has some uh
visual similarities to uh to whatever
this citadel the illuminati is that is
shot in uh in the british museum in
london i love that they use that set um
it's not a set it's a museum but it's it
looks so cool it's one of my favorite
places in the world uh and they just
filled it with these weird looking
statues uh the fact that there's like
four winged statues and that kang he
remains had four statues one of them
broken in his inner chamber the the fact
that like the illuminati is kind of
setting up a judicial body that oversees
multiversal uh
uh criminals you know uh i just think
there's like it feels like kang split
away from somebody and he started his
version of it but didn't give enough of
a [ __ ] to like make it a really cool
looking one and instead just chose his
quirky 70s style bureaucracy just as
like a maddening torture device for
anyone he who gets sucked into it um
like almost felt like he was parodying
the self-seriousness of the illuminati
so he created the tva is like what you
guys are doing is stupid right and i'm
going to show you how stupid it is by
creating my own
but he's still pissed off that he was
like excommunicated from it so i don't
know you could have like a nathaniel
richards be either a founding member or
a past member of it maybe a current
member another nathaniel richards um
variant who wasn't turned because like
this is the council of the smartest
minds in the multiverse and kang is
literally
the smartest mind of the multiverse like
as well as we know so like it would make
sense for him to be part of this group
at some point i mean i would just love
to see uh jonathan majors on that panel
i want to see like john of the majors in
the scene with patrick stewart oh my god
it would be insane
there will be markers and maybe it'll
happen in the future if like kang
himself like kang prime shows up of
course that's i mean kang's coming to
the mcu in all kinds of ways absolutely
um okay so we talked about it tony stark
we see the ultron centuries before we
see anything else right which tells us
that stark tech whether it's ultron or a
version of tony stark himself is showing
up there's been a lot of chatter for
years that at some point in the mc we're
gonna see tom cruise show up as an
alternate version of tony stark which
seems crazy but the fact that toby shows
up patrick stewart shows up can they
convince the insane tom cruise to show
up in this movie i think
playing a very very cool version of tony
stark from another dimension is
something that tom cruise could do a
tropic thunder style cameo to do i bet
you could talk him into doing that oh
yeah for sure i think that he would be
100 game to do that and plus it's a
marvel studios check the man's gonna
take his money and like it would be and
like he was rumored to be uh he wasn't
he like uh in the running to be tony
stark at one point he was back in the
back when they were deciding on robert
downey so it would make a lot of sense
for to like give it to him just be like
hey do you want to be that tony stark
character that you wanted to be even
though it's just a quick cameo and like
they'll probably end up killing him off
like let's be real um and this would be
one that i don't know if we would uh
permanently stay with right like he
would be in this movie and then would
not last beyond it it would be a nice
little like fun cameo for the people
that like knew about his his um trying
out for the role and all that but like i
just don't think it's gonna stick for a
very long time but it does make sense
for a tony stark variant to be on this
council because he's one of the smartest
minds in the marvel universe and he's
all about protecting the multiverse or
the
the people at all costs so he has to be
on this panel those uh handcuffs that
they put doctor strange in seem like a
fusion of like mystic tech like sorcerer
tech the way the runes kind of twist and
lock in place but also it's just so
chunky and metallic it feels like stark
tech it feels like something he designed
to be part of his his ultron century
program and this honestly looks like if
tony stark's ultron protocol was
successful and he could actually have uh
the suit of armor around the world
vision that he pitched in uh straight up
the iron
right there yeah yeah and this is the
iron legion the ultron designs kind of
an ai interface and it works so imagine
what would happen to tony stark if he
was successful in that and just
saved the earth with with the iron
legion all controlled by ultron and it
did actually listen to him and listen to
jarvis you know like this is what we're
seeing now it but also it would give you
a very arrogant tony stark who never
learned his lesson
uh and might just be at the top of his
power the top of his narcissism i'd love
to see what version of tony stark we're
talking about a super tech savvy one but
one that uh has learned nothing you know
if it's tom cruise i hope he jumps on
his chair like the operator
we did mention that um that the captain
marvel x figure in the trailer and how
it could be the superior iron man and um
there is i mean i do think that it's
more likely to be a maria or monica
miramo but um if it was a superior iron
man we do see
that um you know this this figure is
covered in this like orange glow so i'm
just thinking like what if this is a
superior iron man that is that perfected
the killian extremist technology oh and
just operated it into a suit it's like
all right now we can use this power with
my suit to you know just do cool things
because that's the only way i could
really see this being a superior iron
man like people are thinking that it is
because like i don't understand why his
suit would be glowing like that but
that's that's i'm just yeah that's a
good point we would need to see some
kind of technological advancement from
the nanotech
mark 80 or mark 85 i think was the last
we saw tony and i think making it true
bleeding edge something that is inside
of his flesh that comes out of his cells
you know i think that's the way you step
up the game and yeah having something
that's like extremist technology
would be one way to do that for sure
let's talk about three people who we saw
in what if because this trailer very
much feels like what if vibes it's like
yeah canonizing what if officially
they're making it live action there's so
many elements from it there's ultron
infinity seeing those ultron sentries
seem like oh maybe the way they trap
characters like ultron infinity and
killmonger infinity is by forcing them
to be part of this council
i feel like they wouldn't play ball
those two um but realistically do we
think we could see jeffrey wright live
action who want to the watcher on this
panel i feel like he would participate
i feel like we might get a cameo of the
him talking to the council like standing
in front of them and just being like hey
something's going on i think that's
likely because like you don't cast
someone like jeffrey wright and just
only regulate them to
just a voice in an animated show i think
that we'll definitely see him but ultron
infinity on the council would be bonkers
and but i would love it i would love to
see james spader coming back proper and
just doing his thing i mean i think like
uwatu the watcher might consider himself
above the the illuminati council right
even if they are a multiversal one like
he did seem kind of worried that he
violated some rules you know at the end
of what if and then he did it anyway
he's like sure
you go have fun
he did seem to like worry that he was
going to have to have an awkward
conversation with someone that could
have been with the illuminati he could
have been like look i made all these
promises to the illuminati and i
basically just lied so i have to go talk
to them now
um so i don't know if that means he's a
member of them or just like he's kind of
their like elder in the corner who kind
of guides them he could have said maybe
he put this group together and he's like
like i need you guys just to kind of
help keep everything in check to reign
it all in honestly mt i think the most
likely member of the illuminati uh from
what if would be captain carter we saw
her shield show up on the poster yeah
and i honestly believe that weird statue
in the british museum of a warrior with
the sword in a circular ring is a
reference to captain carter's return
from the past after slaying the squid
beast she came in with the sword in a
similar pose through a ring just like
that i think captain carter is either
like their captain america they're like
we have to honor this person she uh is a
multiversal warrior she's the leader of
uh the guardians of the multiverse uh in
her either in her memory or having her
be the founder or kind of the team
captain of that team i think having
hayley at while sitting on that dais by
the others i think that would be perfect
perfect way to bring it back in
absolutely i mean agent carter is a
founding member of shield after all so
having captain carter be a founding
member of whatever this council is makes
a lot of sense because she's just like
tony stark she's all about protecting
people and she's all about i'm doing
whatever um it takes and like she was
one of the founding members of the
guardians of the multiverse so now that
that group has disbanded and she has all
this knowledge of a greater
scope of the the universe of the
multiverse she's gonna want to be on
this on this panel and she's going to be
a valuable um just asset because she is
she's aware of everything going on so
yeah captain carter for sure there's
another opportunity here i don't know
how many of the seats we filled i think
we might have filled six of the seats
right now but we haven't filled six
we're making organization 13.
[Laughter]
right there's like
the neymar represented just kind of the
everybody else the other weirdos on
earth like the kind of wild card spot if
it's not neymar if they don't want to go
there yet if they don't want to use this
opportunity to introduce namor i wonder
if that wild card spot could be seated
by blade or victor von doom someone to
represent the dark magic side yo who's
not necessarily tied in with the doctor
strange sorcerers but a different kind
of like the the supernatural side of the
mcu i mean
yo if we have a multiverse that means
there's going to be a multiverse of like
darker weirder like vampire threats
werewolf threats all those types of
threats so it does make sense for a
blade to be on the council to just sort
of advise on that side of things i mean
though we do have like you know your
doctor strangers and your your um your
mortals potentially on this council um
but i i just think that they deal with a
certain different side of the magic
universe where blade deals with the more
um bloodier and gruesome size right less
less magic and more just stab it you
know so i am yeah i would love to see
blade sitting there i just i just don't
know if he'd be interested in going to
the meetings
i got better stuff to do he's like how
many people do we kill a day
not really a lot he's like
[Laughter]
doom is a huge candidate here because he
is one of the smartest fighters in the
marvel universe and he just he does care
about the preservation of humanity and
in life because he he's just evil he's
just he's he's not a bad dude well he's
a bad dude but he's just he's not super
super evil he doesn't want destruction
he just wants to protect people so he
would be on this council i would love to
see him and
read richards on the same council and
bickering just being like i hate you but
we got to work together to stop this
because there's a greater this is
greater than us yeah i think doom would
be a fast or some version of doom right
um but i think like if we're if we're
imagining people who actually want to
participate in student council in high
school that also rules out people like
deadpool deadpool could cameo in this
movie
very likely what came in this movie i
just don't think he'd be interested in
sitting on that board i don't think they
would want him on that board
but that said i think he's going to show
up in some other way oh yeah he's going
to show him something
totally it'd be weird to just have one
of them be an oddball but what about um
doc ock and norman osborne do you think
that they could potentially be on this
panel in a world where sony is really
heavily involved in this maybe it just
feels like this is now kevin feige's
opportunity to flex right you know i
know sam raimi's directing it i know sam
raimi has these relationships with
willem dafoe with doc and doc definitely
both of them seem very enlightened gents
when they're headed back to their home
realities and potentially with doc one
coming back with stark tech with
advanced tech and might send him now on
a timeline where he can do crazier
experiments i think uh in a world where
i think sony is more altruistic in
helping disney succeed on its own and
sony not really getting much money for
that i think sure
but otherwise i think any cameos in this
movie if marvel spends money but loads
of money getting uh a sony property
cameo in this movie it's gonna be it's
gonna be toby you know it's gonna be one
of these others that we just saw
and uh i could imagine toby sitting on
this panel i mean madame webb seems like
a good person to be sitting on this
panel yo that's a really good idea
because like she was cast and like
maybe there's a reason why she was cats
and that the news came out and that
she's just in multiverse of madness
that's a really good idea my view of
this all is that illuminati is just
going to be specifically mcu uh
leaders of different quarters of the
multiverse and then uh dealing with the
illuminati on the sony side will be
ambassadors from the sony verse like
madame webb you know so they're going to
have their own multiversal body that
sometimes negotiates with the illuminati
[Laughter]
now we're going to talk about how this
group came together some theories there
and what role they're going to play in
the future of the mcu but first
it turns out i'm much better at eating
fancy food than i am at cooking it
sunbasket is here to help me out
sunbasket delivers the joy of eating
with bold flavors organic produce and
sustainable seafood and meats their
award-winning chefs are constantly
innovating with new recipes and global
tastes to keep it interesting each week
with dozens of options some baskets
fresh and ready meals are a perfect hot
lunch hack heat and eat in minutes and
you can put dinner on autopilot with
easy to prep meal kits that impress for
date night or win over the picky eaters
in your family plus they've got healthy
snacks or grab-and-go breakfast items
for busy mornings whether you eat
vegetarian paleo gluten-free or low-carb
sun basket has something for you you can
choose some delicious recipes such as
pan seared salmon tikka masala over
superfood rainbow quinoa or honey
balsamic glazed chicken with warm
cabbage apple salad so set up weekly
delivery and skip a week when you need
to it's simple and easy and you will
love it right now sunbasket is offering
90
off and a free gift when you order go to
sunbasket.com marvel into the promo code
marvel at check out that sunbasket.com
marvel into promo code marvel we also
want to thank stance socks for
sponsoring this episode we're big fans
of the socks from stance here we uh
they're they're super comfortable they
have great designs they have some very
cool designs i like including ones made
in collaboration with wu-tang clan hot
wheels star wars and they are expanding
with all new active apparel line they
have a super soft line of sweat pants
and joggers shirts hoodies hats and more
embrace the life of superior comfort and
creative expression with everyday active
apparel that truly is stitched different
it's always fun when you sit down and
your socks show just a bit under your
pants to reveal that cool design you
know you know that scenario you're
talking about like oh i see what he's
packing down there both the pants and
the socks can become from stance both
the pants so you can show off your pants
and then have another layer a little
russian nesting doll in your lower
regions stance's philosophy is that you
never have to sacrifice your own
individual style for the sake of comfort
and now you don't have to whether you're
relaxing or in the house working out at
the gym or running all over town stance
now delivers its signature softness and
creativity in a full line of active
apparel styles from toe to head stance
has you covered head on over to
stance.com and get 15 off your first
purchase use the promo code marvel at
checkout to apply enjoy the color and
comfort of a life less ordinary with
stance stitched different all right
empty let's talk about our uh our next
theory here uh i kind of want to hear
from you how do you think this version
of the illuminati formed i mean i have
this weird feeling that this console
could have been for me you brought this
up earlier as a response to kang
potentially this could just be
a secret just counsel just to prevent
forces like kang and your you know your
alliance and your your dormammus and all
that from invading our the various
universes so i i don't really know
there's a lot of multiverse madness so
it could be a number of things but what
do you think it could be another thing i
think kang is the likeliest culprit
right uh either he was there at the
beginning and then fell from grace like
lucifer or he started his own kang
empire his own kang dynasty and then
other multiversal figures are like well
we have to have a way to protect us like
like to hear kang tell it to sylvian
loki in that final loki episode it
sounded like he was like the first
scientist to discover the existence of
the multiverse and not maybe maybe to
discover the existence obviously
scientists in our day and age have
already theorized in pine about the
multiverse but actually to shake hands
with a variant of himself it seems like
kang was the first to do that and that's
why he's so powerful now as he kind of
figured it out and then all those kings
killed each other off and there was one
one last survivor gang that was the most
fearsome and the deadliest he is really
the one who made the multiverse such a
mess and and rigged it and the way it is
so rigged now uh created this this
sacred timeline and created this
situation where
branches are just
you know
crossing the wrong street causes
everything to fall apart like it
shouldn't be that way it should allow to
be flexible into ebb and flow and
without having to prune things you know
right so i think he's the one who kind
of rigged it a specific way and needs it
to go a specific way uh meanwhile you've
had other other characters who in their
timelines have
made the same discoveries just like
it's hard to say win it's hard to say
compare time here because it's all kind
of happening at the same time but just
like
we're late to the the four-dimensional
game compared to kang characters like
this version of charles xavier this
version of iron man etc uh so they've
kind of rallied together and i do like
this idea that if it's not kang himself
that
his descendant or his really his
ancestor reed richards is the one who
realized the future of what his family
tree creates uh and
tries to get ahead of it and tries to
respond to it just because in the comics
reed richards is really the one who
kind of is the most aggressive with
trying to use the multiverse to solve
problems for sure he's the one who
thinks the hardest about this stuff i
mean i would like a trash can to the
negative zone for a bit
which is kind of funny
yeah
right like this is the guy who i would
imagine approaching five other people
and saying look okay so i'm gonna have
uh a thousand years from now a
descendant of mine is really just gonna
screw everything up it's already
happened
so can you help me you're really smart
can you help me
uh just kind of rain things in with it
with a governing body it's just so
interesting that in the trailer patrick
stewart says we should tell him the
truth and i and i'm dying to know what
that truth is i think the truth is that
like
really it's not your fault everything is
screwed up it's this guy's fault and
reed is like guilty sorry
um so we need you to help us fix it
you're really great at this i also just
like the truth that like simply they the
mcu we've been living in is
is wrong because it doesn't have mutants
in it and we've just been gas-lit from
the beginning that it's okay not to have
anything bananas and they're like so
we're gonna fix that
and it seems like what this movie is
destined to do especially with the most
famous mutant
from movies in it
wolverine might be more famous but um
yeah this is true now uh one more
question we want to address what's gonna
happen to the illuminati after this
movie or in this movie before we get to
that we want to thank helix for
sponsoring this episode mt and i have to
be on our a game during inside marvel
recording sessions we do it early in the
morning sometimes after getting four
hours of sleep and uh we can't afford to
have a bad night of sleep because of a
crappy mattress that's why we love our
helix mattresses helix sleep has as a
quiz that matches your body type and
your sleep preference is the perfect
mattress for you they have soft medium
and burn mattresses mattress is great
for cooling you down if you sleep hot
even a helix plus mattress for plus size
sleepers i have a helix mattress i love
it mt's helix mattress is getting
delivered soon so he's gonna report back
on how much he loves it in future
episodes so this mattress ships right to
your door for free no need to go to a
mattress store just uh go to
helixsleep.com inside marvel take their
two minute sleep quiz and they'll match
you to a customized mattress that will
give you the best sleep of your life and
they have a 10 year warranty you get to
try it out for 100 tonight's risk free
they'll even pick it up for you if you
don't love it but i think you're gonna
love it helix is offering up to 200 off
all mattress orders and two free pillows
for our listeners at helixsleep.com
inside marvel and we want to thank
bluetooth for sponsoring this episode
we're pretty confident in our theories
here at inside marvel but confidence can
take you pretty far in life and in the
bedroom and that's where bluetooth comes
in bluetooth is a unique online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis but in
chewable tablets and at a fraction of
the cost you can plan ahead be ready for
when opportunity arises the process is
simple sign up at bluetooth.com consult
with one of their licensed medical
providers and once you're approved
you'll receive your prescription within
days it's all done online so no visits
to the doctor's office no awkward
conversations no waiting in the line the
pharmacy bluetooth tablets are made in
the usa they prepare and ship direct to
your door to discreet package so if you
could benefit from some extra confidence
when it's time to form bluetooth can
help you and we've got a special deal
for our listeners try bluetooth free
when you use our promo code marvel at
checkout just pay the five dollars in
shipping that's bluetooth.com promo code
marvel to receive your first month free
visit bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information we thank
bluetooth for sponsoring the show all
right mt uh our last question we'll talk
about in this episode what role do you
think the illuminati will play in the
future of the mcu
um
well i think that uh the illuminati
whether or not it's going to be this
particular people on the panel i think
that in the future the mcu we're going
to be dealing with the incursions and
what the incursions are they're
basically um the precursor to the secret
war scenario where
the different timelines or universes are
kind of just crossing over with each
other and basically one universe has to
die in order for
the other universe to live so i think
that they're setting it up this scenario
by introducing the illuminati in this
movie and then having the illuminati
just sort of be like the the avengers or
like the the force sort of dealing with
this bigger threat of like all right
everything's breaking for real and like
the timelines are coming together so
like we have to stop this so i think
that that's that's sort of like what
we're getting here but what do you think
yeah i think that's a really good idea
empty especially if we assume that the
next avengers movie is going to be
secret wars i think if you imagine like
a world war breaking up literally a
world's war breaking out right uh who is
the the governing body the league of
nations trying to prevent that from
happening and i think that's the
illuminati in this case right they're
gonna try to use negotiation uh try to
use diplomacy to try to prevent those
threats from breaking out into an
all-out war and i think when this group
inevitably fails that's when we're gonna
have secret war
um happening on battle world maybe you
have a doctor doom is just like screw
that that governing body it's gonna be
more fun if we could have spider-man
fighting hulk you know
please battle world please battle world
yeah i love it but i think ultimately we
should look at this organization as like
rather than a definitive never changing
body like the time keepers of loki these
are really just puppets that are
destined to be uh slain or replaced uh
or not to say that we'll never see any
of them ever show up again in the mcu i
think if they show up one second they're
gonna be whack-a-moles they're going to
show up everywhere
but realistically this exact lineup is
probably going to change out we're going
to have different people jump in it's
it's going to be like who's on the
illuminati this week black panther was a
sort of he was introduced to be part of
it then he leaves and then i think
charles xavier dies in the comics and
then he comes back to uh to fulfill that
role if i'm not mistaken then him and
neymar kind of butt heads for a little
bit um but yeah no for sure the lineup
is can definitely change i can i can
definitely see it changing in the mcu
you're going to see wanda or kang kill
off some of these characters oh it's
gonna be hilarious it's gonna be great
it's gonna be really tragic and like
crazy but like i don't think tom cruise
stands a chance he's a gunner uh but the
way some of these are gonna be
introduced are to be kind of jokey and i
think it's going to feel right when
wanda comes in there and wrecks the
place you know some of them it's going
to be really sad like i think it's hard
it was really hard to see patrick
stewart's character die in logan
so to see it happen again i don't know
if i really want to see that but like
we've seen him die like twice
so far so like three times that's right
he died like so many times in the x-men
movies he died in last stand i think
he's implied he died in some other way i
think uh he almost died in days of
future past but i i'm so excited that
he's part of this universe now because
it's just just introducing him as marvel
fans know mean that anybody can be
introduced like that's the dam has
already been broken we're already living
in this world original recipe howard the
duck is coming
i mean that's why i think just this
moment in the trailer
it's like seeing spider-man show up in
civil war that was the game-changing
moment wasn't the movie itself it was
the moment in november 2015
that was the game-changing moment that
told every marvel fan that we're now
living in this world
uh so that's that's why this is such a
watershed moment that's why i lost my
mind in the trailer reaction uh i think
just hearing his voice in that trailer
that's bro that's the game changer it is
the game changer man for sure like it's
it's bananas seeing like our all of our
toys getting to play together now like
there's no more sony fox it's just like
all right now our toys are here and
that's so exciting well that is it for
this episode of inside marvel obviously
we're gonna be talking about this a lot
more on the channel forever uh now don't
forget to check out our many great merch
options over at newrockstarsmerch.com if
you're over 18 click the link for new
rockstar's discord server in the
description join that conversation
follow me at eavos follow mt
mastertainment subscribe to inside
marvel wherever you get your podcast
thank you for watching see you next week
bye
[Music]
you